the design was for pavilion for Archie
fest 2014 so we called it whew 1357 so
when we first started the design we felt
that we wanted to create a series of
spaces which are quite monumental and
any cow grew and as a things go it ended
up before most 3885 schools thus to
essentially was the key object if you to
invert this you realize that actually
you no longer really see it as a stew
and especially when you actually put
this on like this you start to lose the
sense of the object and if it multiplies
to 3885 you completely do not see the
object anymore and what you see is
actually the space that we want to
communicate to you and so that is how
the design evolved eventually you start
to realize that indeed it is true this
these tools can become architecture and
architecture can be formed out of
anything that you find and as you go
through the space you realize that you
will also encounter sounds and that is
why is few 1357 the challenging part at
3885 stools to the director in 10 days
that is the logistical challenge it is
all hand put together the president
designer one has a cost influence design
because it is another one of these
aspirational target called a landmark
and in many cases a lot of the designers
who are actually given this recognition
actually become much more encouraged you
know that there is such a referential I
think that's very important when it
comes to awards advice for emerging
designers you know you're starting out
you just have to keep going and work
hard I think that is the simple truth of
the matter